nichts gegen Spaß überhaupt nicht und
auch glaube ich dass die Summen über die
wir jetzt reden die sind geringer als
das Geld was wir bräuchten um diese
Investitionen zu finanzieren die
sicherlich wahnsinnig sinnvoll ist aber
das was mich jetzt umtreibt ist
sicherlich für den Spaß total gut den
junge Leute haben sollen ohne Frage wir
alle waren jung hatten viel Spaß aber
die Frage ist muss das eigentlich auf
Kosten des Steuerzahlers passieren da
sage ich ganz klar nein nein zu einem
stärker
ausufern denn Nanny Staat was passiert
ähm die Bundesregierung will
Jugendlichen oder jungen Erwachsene ab
18 Jahren im nächsten Jahr eine
Kulturkarte wird von 200 € schenken
jeder 18-Jährige soll die bekommen soll
damit Museen gehen können aber auch in
Kinos also feiern tanzen auf Kosten der
Steuerzahler da sage ich ganz klar nein
denn wir wissen auch dieses Geld muss
irgendwann erwirtschaftet werden die
müssen lernen wie man sich selbst das
Feiern erwirtschaftet und sollen nicht
irgendwie ja zum Spaß gezwungen werden
das ist glaube ich der falsche